le deuxième sujet suite la délinquance
dont j'entends bien la question alors
évidemment est-ce que je connais à caen
il me semble que depuis deux ans je la
condamne et je la condamne fortement est
ce qu'on aurait pu lutter davantage
contre la délinquance évidemment
pourquoi cette délinquance a été de
façon plus importante que dans les
autres matches je pense avoir expliqué
c'est parce que le dispositif de
sécurité hors public a été levée
notamment pour pouvoir sauver des vies
qui consistait à l'écrasement aux
débordements des personnes extrêmement
nombreuses parce qu en surnombre et
parce qu'avec des faux billets ou parce
que sans billet qui se présentait la
décision prise par la préfecture de
police à sauver des vies la conséquence
a en effet été le livret le terrain
comme vous dites monsieur le sénateur à
une délinquance que les policiers
appellent d'opportunité je l'évoqué je
les dis je n'ai pas à le cacher il est
difficile de la mesurer complètement
c'est pour ça que dans une formule tout
à fait originale est tout à fait
novatrice nous proposons à chacune et à
chacun de pouvoir déposer plainte et
compris la part de citoyens qui n'est
pas votre pays qui ne sont pas notre
pays qui sont repartis donc
effectivement il ya eu cette difficulté
mais je trouve que à la fin de la part
la sénatrice êtes vous-même de
qu'évoquer avec beaucoup d' insulte la
seine saint denis et qui depuis
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
évoque une essentialisation la
délinquance en évoquant des nationalités
en mettant en pâture un certain nombre
de liens très nauséabond qui font
malheureusement l'écho d'une campagne
présidentielle que pourtant les
extrémistes ont perdu je la trouve pas
seulement être extrêmement déplacé je
vous le dis comme je le pense je vous le
dis exactement comme je le pense si si
je pense que non mais il faut assumer le
fait qu'il ya une forme il ya une forme
manifeste quand vous dites madame que
depuis 4 à 18 la france n'est plus la
même et cassany a changé vous faites le
jeu je crois de partie assez extrêmes et
je veux dire ici
je veux dire je veux dire madame que je
suis personnellement et j'ai mon endroit
et mon opinion j'ai le droit d'être
d'être assez choqué par ce point et je
n'ai pas et puisqu'on m'a forcé à le
faire pour lutter contre l'effet que
nous a donné des nationalités des
personnes que nous interpellons et je
suis d'ailleurs j'imagine que la
prochaine question ce sera quel type de
français avant nous interpeller mais je
n'ai pas encore cette question à ce
niveau mais je m'y attendais bien
évidemment je veux dire cependant que
sur les interpellations qui ont lieu la
justice poursuit ces personnes et quand
on me dit il n'y a pas eu de citoyens
britanniques de se terrer pour intrusion
ou pour faux billets qui ont été mis en
garde à vue d'abord on a présenté 14
citoyens britanniques pour les
intrusions à la justice c'est normal de
les relâcher si l'audience qu'ils
apprenaient leur train ou l'avion ou la
voiture le soir même je sais que c'est
pas moi qui les relâchent un vote au
courant que ces autorités judiciaires
qu'il le fait et deuxièmement quand vous
n'y a pas de gens qui ont été arrêtés
pour des phobies c'est pas vrai et des
gens qui ont été porteurs de faux
billets en grand nombre qui ont été
interpellées et d'ailleurs ça fait
l'écho d'un article de presse sans
aucune espèce de discrétion mais surtout
les policiers d'ordre public et il
n'interprète pas les gens quand ils ont
un faux billets quand on est policier
d'ordre public ou gendarmes mobiles et
qu'on a en face de soi une foule de
milliers de personnes qui force et
notamment dans des prés filtrage qui
sont faits par des stadiers d'abord
c'est pas le policier qui constate le
faux billets c'est bien la personne qui
embauchait agents de sécurité privés
lust alliés donc il ne peut pas à
interpeller quelqu'un qui a un faux
billets je veux dire skali la fédération
française de football madame la mise
pour emporter témoin dans la réunion de
riz texte du lundi matin c'est qu'au
début il pensait même que des stylos
chimiques qu'ils avaient livré était
faux puisque la quasi intégralité des
billets qui étaient vérifiées seulement
du côté britannique je veux dire que
toute cette histoire ne fonctionne que
dans les trois portes du stade de france
qui comporte 75 mille personnes et
comporte je crois une quinzaine de porte
ils ont tous ont cru que c'était faux
que tous les stades i o stopper l'entrée
en faisant remonter à la fédération
française de football que les stylos ne
marchait pas et d'ailleurs la personne
qui était en charge de ça nous a dit
mais on leur a dit que ce n'est pas vrai
mais c'est une garantie 2 ans ils sont
venus vérifier eux-mêmes et partout
ailleurs les stylos fonctionné puisque
c'était des vrais billets et donc oui
les policiers dans leur public n'ont pas
à ce moment-là interpeller des personnes
qui a des faux billets parce qu'ils
avaient autre chose à faire il avait à
gérer une foule avec des enfants des
femmes enceintes des personnes qui
venaient faire la fête comme dit
monsieur assouline est donc en effet la
consigne donnée à des policiers dans le
public c'est pas d'arrêter des gens qui
avaient des faux billets c'est de gérer
une foule je l'assumé bien volontiers et
si c'est ça la faute qu'a fait la police
nationale gendarmerie c'est une faute
que l'on peut gagner mais en tout cas
contraire aux règles d'emploi d'emploi
[Musique]